protesters encounter protests supporters
of Iraq's coordination framework
gathered near bardad's Green Zune
they're denouncing what they consider a
coup by rival Shia leader muktada Sada
and his followers
we are here to regain the legitimacy of
the state institutions that has been
violated by the occupation of the
parliament at the hands of the sadris we
try to keep it peaceful
but violence erupted as they headed
towards the green zone
forcing security Personnel to pull out
chanting against caretaker prime
minister mustafal Academy they accused
him of collaborating with a solder to
remain in power the reports of military
units within rival factions being
deployed nearby to protect their people
so many fear it could get worse
opposing groups have been intensifying
their campaigns and seem to be pushing
for a showdown
foreign
supporters have staged a sit in at the
Parliament building
a top leader with the coordination
framework has warned of Bloodshed and
called for dialogue
this escalation comes against the
backdrop of leaked audio recordings
attributed to former prime minister
nurile Maliki where he is hard insulting
al-solder and his Affiliates the
southerners have requested that
al-maliki recordings be condemned as a
prerequisite for dialogue
we will remain here until our leader
instructs us to leave it's not just a
political dispute it's rather a
revolution against Decades of corruption
and oppression
the conflict over forming a government
started here among lawmakers months ago
but these protesters say they not only
follow their leaders but they also want
to change the whole political system
foreign